1301 and the Byzantine Empire looked
like this by 1450 it looked like this
the primary reason for this was the
ottomans who had begun a long period of
expansion under the guidance of several
very gifted rulers called Sultan's one
such ruler was Murat the first who
conquered the important Byzantine city
of Adrianople in the 1360s
over the next century the ottomans
continued to expand in both europe and
asia into a 1451 when the Empire looked
like this and encircled the Byzantine
city of Constantinople what was left of
the Byzantine Empire at this point was a
vassal state to the ottomans and
Constantinople had seen a major
population reduction over the previous
century many of the wealthy and educated
who fled Constantinople ended up in
Italy in the texts and knowledge they
brought with them had a profound effect
on the Renaissance whilst Constantinople
paled in comparison to its former glory
it was still valuable it controlled
trade between the Black Sea in the
Mediterranean and contained the shortest
crossing point between both parts of the
Ottoman domain Constantinople was also
important symbolically it represented
the apex of bottom and ambitions at the
time as one of the most important
Christian cities too many Ottomans
conquering Constantinople would
represent a major victory of Islam over
Christianity so in 1451 mehmet ii became
Sultan of the Ottoman Empire for the
second time after his father Murat ii
died unfortunately for mehmet his uncle
Orhan who is a potential claimant to the
throne was residing in Constantinople in
the custody of the byzantine emperor
constantine xi who basically threatened
to release him unless he was given more
money this was just one more reason to
capture Constantinople and so Mehmet
brought 50,000 men with him to lay siege
to the city the Byzantines refused to
surrender and requested help from their
fellow Christians who responded with
Venice and Genoa did send some soldiers
to Constantinople but it was nowhere
near enough to change the course of the
battle due in no small part to a
humongous cannon and the elite
Janissaries the city fell after a 54 day
siege because the city refused to
surrender it was heavily plundered the
many of its people were either killed or
sold into slavery
Mehmet made sure that certain parts of
the city such as the Hagia Sophia were
spared since he intended on making
Constantinople the Ottoman capital the
fall of Constantinople was viewed with
horror by the Christians of Europe er
many popes called for a crusade to
retake the city again nobody really
wanted to help and so Pope Pius ii
decided he would lead a crusade
personally but he died before anything
happened so confident Opel's capture cut
Europe off from the Black Sea trade and
made the Ottomans wealthier because now
they could
shipping the Venetians were quick to
strike a deal with the Ottomans to
continue trading in Constantinople
because money the fall of Constantinople
is without a doubt one of the most
important events in world history it
marked the end of the Roman Empire
allowed the Ottomans to secure their
position and free in Greek spurred on
Renaissance thinking Constantinople
demise is so important that some
historians consider at the end of the
medieval era and the beginning of the
early modern period in his new capital
Mehmet had the Hagia Sophia church
transformed into a mosque and also built
a brand new palace from which the Empire
could be run the administration that ran
the Ottoman Empire was centered around
the Imperial Household which included
the Sultan and those closest to him
immediately surrounding the Sultan was
his harem his personal household in
which lived many concubines by whom he
would have many children
these women were extremely influential
and the Sultan's favorites could often
get their children much better chances
the Sultanate do not simply pass from
father 12 his son like in European
monarchies after the death of a sultan
his male offspring would often raise
armies or assassinate one another for
the imperial crown the Sultan could pick
favorites though would often place his
preferred air near the capital so that
news of his death would reach them first
also inside the Imperial Household were
eunuchs who were trusted to go into the
harem for obvious reasons as well as the
eunuchs were the Sultan slaves many of
whom have very prestigious
administrative in military positions
these slaves made up a large chunk of
the Ottoman government the majority of
these slaves came through the dev sheer
may assist in where Christian boys often
from the Balkans were taken from their
families and converted to Islam in order
to serve the Sultan families were often
compensated for this but unsurprisingly
this didn't make up for the fact that
they had their children taken from them
it should be remembered that for some
this was seen as the best opportunity
for their children to experience social
mobility though a Christian peasant
farmer had nowhere near the levels of
opportunity that a slave in the Sultan's
household would so the dev she may had
two outcomes the smarter ones would
become administrators some of whom
became extremely powerful others would
be forced to join the Janissaries as
infantrymen in many respects this method
of recruitment was a way of taxing
non-muslims in the Empire and also got
around Islam's ban on believers
enslaving each other
however the ottomans were in some
respects more tolerant than others when
it came to religious differences and
providing they pay taxes and say loyalty
and Jews would live mostly under their
own rules so just beneath the Sultan
with the Grand Vizier who was
essentially a prime minister the Grand
Vizier was a part of what is called the
divan which was an advisory council to
the
so with Constantinople conquered the
Ottomans were free to focus on expansion
elsewhere and the head lots of options a
decade after the fall of Constantinople
the Ottomans found themselves at war
with Venice which the Ottomans won due
to a major naval buildup by the end of
the 16th century the Empire steadily
expanded until it looked like this
the next major period of expansion began
with the ascension of Sultan Selim in
1512 in 1514 Selim went to war with Shah
Ismail of the Safavid Empire and was
victorious gaining this territory two
years later he turned his gaze to the
Mamluks and invaded in 1516 and within a
year the Mamluk Empire had collapsed and
the ottomans were in control of all of
this territory notably including the
holy cities of Mecca and Medina one of
the main reasons for victory was that
the ottomans had a much better
understanding of gunpowder weapons and
importantly had more of them controlling
the two most holy sites in Islam meant
that from then on the Ottoman Sultans
could style themselves as Calif a
successor to Muhammad giving the
Sultan's a major boost to their prestige
it also meant that the ottomans were now
responsible for keeping the pilgrims to
Mecca safe and thus the identity of the
Ottoman state became inseparable from
that of Islam itself this is
demonstrated by the fact that the
Ottoman Crescent is often seen as the
symbol of Islam despite it not having
any official symbols furthermore all of
this territory meant that the Ottomans
had a monopoly on overland trade between
Europe and China which meant that
Europeans were incentivized to look
elsewhere mostly West so like most
mortals Selim eventually died and was
succeeded by his son soon him on the
first in 1520 Suleiman the first is
better known as Suleiman the Magnificent
which will tell you that he was kind of
important Suleiman was quick to follow
in his father's footsteps by conquering
Belgrade and Rhodes shortly after that
unlike Mehmet and Saleem Suleiman faced
much tougher military resistance in the
form of two major opponents the first
was the Habsburg monarchy led by the
king of Spain and Holy Roman Emperor
Carlos the first better known as Charles
v the second opponent was Portugal who
by 1520 were well established in the
Indian Ocean trade network and weren't
keen on the Ottomans being there or
anywhere really the first roadblock to
what him an expansion in Europe was the
Kingdom of Hungary which was led by King
Louie the second after the capture of
Belgrade there was no real line of
defense against the Ottomans which meant
that it was ripe for the taking in 1526
Suleiman invaded and at first was met
with little resistance eventually the
Hungarians faced the Ottoman at the
Battle of Mohawk to summarize the
Hungarians were massively outnumbered
and outgunned the result was essentially
a slaughter which even saw King
we died after fleeing the battlefield
the Ottomans were then free to march on
the mostly abandoned Hungarian capital
Budapest
this was a big deal because Hungary was
an extremely wealthy and powerful
Kingdom and its demise shifted the
balance of power in southeastern Europe
to the Ottomans also Ferdinand of
Austria became the king of Hungary and
gained these valuable territories for
the hapsburgs
so there was only one response by
European rulers to the fall of Hungary
to use a technical term there bricked it
the Ottomans were now able to strike at
the heart of the Austrian realm which
they did in 1529 when they laid siege to
Vienna
they siege failed and by 1541 the
borders between the Ottomans and
Habsburg had largely stabilized in the
decades following my heart the ottomans
expanded their holdings in north africa
which soon included what is known as the
Barbary Coast from which pirates preyed
upon European shipping these territories
were kept in line by the huge Ottoman
Navy which was vital to protecting the
Empire from powerful Christian navies
such as those owned by Venice or Spain
the mid 16th century saw a major uptick
in the number of naval clashes between
Christian Europeans and the Ottomans
Ottoman setbacks included failing to
break the Portuguese hold over the
Indian Ocean and its failure to capture
molten 1565 despite having a massively
superior force the Ottoman advances into
Europe were beginning to stall and this
was made worse by the death of Suleiman
the next year
he was succeeded by Salim the second
better known as Salim the drunkard
because apparently magnificence isn't
hereditary much like his father Salim
expanded the Empire began a campaign to
increase Ottoman influence over the
Mediterranean in 1570 the Ottomans
seized Cyprus from Venice which gave
them a firm grip over the eastern half
of the Mediterranean this left the
Ottomans free to expand into the western
Mediterranean which worried the
Christian powers notably the papal
States which were not keen on the idea
of an ottoman fleet turning up on their
Shores
after a plea from Venice pope pius v
formed the holy league to challenge the
ottomans it included all of these
christian kingdoms and republics and its
sole purpose was to reduce Ottoman
influence by destroying the now very
powerful Ottoman Navy the holy League
built up their own Navy under the
command of John of Austria and on the
7th of October 1571 it met the Ottoman
Navy here what is called the Battle of
Lepanto Lepanto was a stunning success
for the Christians and the Ottomans
suffered massive losses importantly the
ottomans lost a huge number of skilled
sailors and infantry which meant that
the naval capabilities were severely
hampered for several reasons Lepanto is
one of the more important battles in
European history first it ended the
momentum of Ottoman expansion and the
Ottomans would thereafter struggle to
break out of the eastern Mediterranean
it also marked the end of combat with
old ships carrying infantry and the
ottomans struggled to keep up with
spanish and portuguese sailing
advancements the holy league did not
capitalize on their victory in venice
was unable to reclaim cyprus the Ottoman
Empire had been slowed but ultimately it
stood just as strong as ever in
conclusion the rise of the Ottomans is
one of the most compelling and important
events in European Asian and African
history the Ottoman Empire swelled
rapidly swallowing empires taking holy
cities and amassing unmatched wealth the
Ottoman expansion gave way to the
Renaissance the discovery of America by
destroying Hungary inadvertently
increased the power of the Hapsburgs
this great expansion was overseen by a
complex and highly efficient bureaucracy
and enforced by a strong military
however many of those who served in
these ultimately did so against their
will at least initially I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching
you